let's do a couple of warm-up problems
converting fractions to percentages and
then converting percentages to fractions
and then we can do some actual word
problems
so our first warm-up let's convert 5
over 24 to a percentage and the way I
like to do it I like to convert it to a
decimal first and once you have it in
the decimal form it's pretty
straightforward to convert it to a
percentage so the way you convert it to
a decimal is you divide the denominator
into the numerator this can literally be
read it's 5 divided by 24 so let's do a
little bit of division 24 goes into 5
and we're going to have to add some
extra spaces to the 5 because obviously
this is going to be less than 1 24 is a
larger number than 5 so let's put our
decimal right there and we can now do
some division 24 goes in to 5 0 times 0
times 24 is 0 5 minus 0 is 5 bring down
this 0 right here 24 goes into 50 well
it goes into that 2 times all right 2
times 24 is 2 times 4 is 8 2 times 2 is
now we subtract 50 minus 48 is to bring
down another 0 we're gonna keep bringing
down zeros until we have no remainder so
bring down another 0 24 goes into 20 0
times 0 times 24 is 0 20 minus 0 is 20
let's bring down another 0 let's bring
down another 0 24 goes into 200 24 goes
into 200 let's see 8 times maybe 9 times
its 180 now it'll be 8 times I believe
let's see if 8 time works there's always
a little bit of an art to this this is
too little we might have to increase it
8 times 4 is 32 30
- 8 times 2 is 16 plus 3 is 19 know that
that was right 8 times 200 minus 192
that's 8 that is 8 bring down another 0
bring down another 0 24 goes into 80 3
times can be 4 times 3 times 3 times 4
is 12 carry the 1 3 times 2 is 6 add 170
and then you have another 80 you bring
down another 0 we have an infinite
supply of zeros here as we need them now
we're gonna have another 80
well once again 24 is going to go into
that 3 times is we're gonna start
repeating these threes over and over and
over again so 5 over 24 let me write
this down 5 over 24 I want you
understand why it keeps repeating every
time we do this now we're gonna get a 3
and come down get a 70 - 80 from 72 or
you get another 80 we're just gonna have
a big string of threes there so 5
divided by 24 is zero point two zero
eight three repeating now if we want to
write this as a percentage the word
percentage the word percent / let me
split it up percent cent comes from the
word 400 this is per hundred so what is
this this is 0.2 Oh what is this /
hundred we're a hundred is a whole and
that might confuse or might not but one
way you could view this is this is the
same thing as you could view it as this
way this is the same thing this decimal
zero point two oh eight three repeating
is the same thing as twenty point eight
three repeating over 100 this is how
many we have per hundred percent or you
could say that this is equal to twenty
point eight three repeating percent per
100 these are equivalent a very quick
way to think about how to go from
decimals to percent as you can multiply
by
100 and then put the percentage sign or
if you go backwards you divide by a
hundred and get rid of the percentage
sign that was a good warm-up let's do
let's do one more let's convert a pret
percentage into a fraction I'll do it in
blue so let's say we have 16% 16%
remember this means 16 per hundred so
this is the same thing as 16 per hundred
that's what per cent century is a
hundred years there are a hundred cents
in a dollar so 16 over 100 put that in
the lowest cut let's see we can divide
the numerator denominator by 4 we get 4
over 25
so that's our warm-up let's do some
actual problems now all right they tell
us a TV is advertised on sale it is 35
percent off and has a new price of a
hundred ninety five dollars what was the
pre sale price so if X is the pre sale X
is the pre sale price when you take 35
percent off of that it has a new price
of one hundred ninety five dollars
so X minus 35 percent of X 0.35 is the
same thing as 35 percent so if I take X
and I subtract 35 percent of X from X
I'm going to get one hundred and ninety
five dollars that's what that is telling
me so now we just solve for X so you can
view this as 1x 1x minus 0.35 X that
will be 0.65 X so this is 0.65 X right
if you add point six five two point
three five you get one right one minus
0.35 is 0.65 X is equal to 195 and now
you can divide both sides of this
equation actually I like to do it more
as a fraction so let me write it that
way so if you have 65 over 100 X is
equal to 195 now we can multiply both
sides of this equation by the inverse
even before I do that let me simplify
this fraction I can divide the numerator
in the denominator by 5 and this becomes
13 over 20 so we get 13 over 20 X is
equal to 195 and now we can multiply
both sides by the inverse of this so 20
over 13 times that is equal to 195 times
20 over 13 these cancel out and we get X
is equal to 195 times 20 over 13 which
we could figure out but I'll take the
calculator out for this one
so you see you get 195 times 20 divided
by divided by 13 is equal to $300 I
should have done that on so this is
equal to that right there is equal to
three hundred dollars so 195 is actually
divisible by 13 or I should be able to
do that without a calculator anyway so
the original price was $300 you take 35%
of $300 which is a hundred and five
dollars and you will be left with one
hundred and ninety five dollars so that
was our original price one let's do
another one an employee at a store is
currently paid $9 50 per hour if she
works a full year she gets a 12 percent
pay raise what will be her new hourly
rate after the raise so today she makes
950 she works for 12 years she'll make
950 plus 12% plus let me write it this
way plus 12% times 950 that's how much
her raise will be so her new hourly wage
will be this entire thing well we could
view it this way this is the same thing
as 950 950 plus point zero point one two
times 950 this is the same thing as 1
times 950 times zero point one two times
950 so this is the same thing as 1 point
1 2 I'm just adding that let me do this
in a different color I'm just adding
that and
that to get that x times 9:50 we are
growing 950 by 12% you already have the
950 plus another 12% its 1.1 2 times 950
is going to be equal to our new number
let me multiply this out I don't just to
make up for me using the calculator the
last time so 950 times 1/12 2 times 0 is
0 2 times 5 is 10 2 times 9 is 18 plus 1
is 19 it'll put a 0 here 1 times you
just 1 times 0 is 0 1 times 5 is 5 1
times 9 is 9 let's put it up put 2
zeroes here 1 times 0 is 0 1 times 5 is
5 1 times 9 is 9 and now we can add now
we can add the 0 is that up to 0 0 is
that up to 0 9 plus 5 is 14 2 plus 9 is
11 plus 5 is 16 16 1 plus 9 is 10 and
then we count the number of decimal we
have 1 2 3 4 numbers behind the decimal
so in our answer we have to have 1 2 3 4
numbers behind the decimal so her new
salary will be 10 dollars and 64 cents
per hour 10 dollars and 64 you don't
have to write those trailing zeros right
there so this is her new hourly rate
after the raise all right let's do one
more one more store a and store B both
sell bikes and both buy bikes from the
same supplier at the same price store a
has a forty percent markup story has a
forty percent markup that means whatever
they buy the bike for they sell it for
forty percent above that while store B
has a fifty two hundred fifty percent
store B has a two hundred and fifty
percent markup store B has a permanent
sale and always will sell
66% off those prices which store has a
better deal so let's say that there's
both buying the bike so let's X is equal
to the price from supplier price from
supplier so that's the price that both
bike stores buy their bicycles at right
they both buy bikes from the supplier at
the same price that's this X that I'm
going to start off with now let's do the
scenario of store a what does store a
sell their bike for they sell the bike
for X plus 40% of X plus 40% of X which
is equal to 1.4 times X that's how much
store a sells their bike for now store B
is a little bit more interesting store B
so they have a 250% markup so they sell
the will they claim to sell their bike
for X plus 250 percent that's the same
thing as to 0.5 times X a hundred
percent markup would literally mean
another X this is 250 percent you know
as we said you can just divide by a you
can just divide by 100 you get 2.5 get
rid of the percentage sign so they sell
it X plus 2.5 X which is equal to 3.5 x
that's kind of their ticket price but
then they sell at a 60% off those prices
so they take 60% off of this price right
here so the real selling price is going
to be three point five times the price
from the supplier minus 0.6 minus 0.6
minus 60% of this price of 3.5 X and we
could view this as one times three point
five X minus 0.6 times three point five
x and that's the same thing as 1 minus
zero point six times 3.5 X this is going
to be 0.4 this is zero point four so if
you're getting 60% off it's equivalent
of selling it at 40% of the ticket price
what we're doing right there you might
eventually do this in your head
immediately say Oh 60% off is the same
thing as selling at 40% or selling at
point four of the price 5x and let's
multiply that out so if we take three
point five times zero point four four
times five is twenty four times three is
12 plus 2 is 14 and we have one two
numbers behind the decimal spot two
numbers one to one point four so they're
going to sell it at one point for X so
in either store you're actually gonna
pay the same price let's say they buy
the bikes from the supplier at $100 then
in store a you're gonna pay $140 for
that bike and store B you're going to
spend $140 for that bike but it store B
you think you're getting 60% off